from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between Pringles in Italy and the US
this is food
Wars here are all the exclusive flavors
that you will find in Italy that you
won't get in the US here are all the US
Pringles you're not going to find in
Italy starting from paprika I've got to
say paprika is something that's very
popular in
Spain yeah it's quite nice actually for
those who made on know what paprika is
it's actually dried uh crushed red
pepper very fruity and fresh in a way I
know you guys in the US have a barbecue
flavor we actually have Texas barbecue I
don't know is there maybe any difference
or maybe this is just marketing to
appeal to the Italians because when you
say Texas
barbecue feels cooler and we already
know what it
is I don't know it's barbecue sauce
again is barbecue sauce in Texas
supposed to taste different the US
actually has dozens of regional barbecue
Styles including Texas which has at
least fours so it depends on who you ask
and I don't know where barbecue started
yeah we also have just
barbecue and I described the flavor
Tangy good though I love barbecue and
then onto the exclusive train we've got
ketchup H I think it's a bit too strong
I prefer the other ones the queen of
them all the pizza flavored as I should
be I'm a little bit worried about those
because as an Italian I'm very vocal
about what pizza is I have pretty low
expectations for these just because
everything Pizza flavor to me it's like
a bit of a
gimmick no they just taste like oregano
so I don't know why you guys have this
idea that like Italians love oregano so
much like I have so many spices and like
herbs in my kitchen and guess what's
missing oregano weirdly and maybe I'm
going to be cancelled for this but the
ketchup ones taste more like pizza
because they taste more like tomatoes
then we've got Smokey
bacon they taste more like the oil you
cook the bacon in no F you may also be
able to find Amal Pringles but we were
not able to track them down so ow is a
Swiss cheese made in the German part of
Switzerland oh cheddar cheese let's go
bursting with
flavor good been on screen good oo I've
never had this one before hot
honey nope ah cheddar and sour cream
dude these are always good M the chave
Sal vinegar got Ranch not the best Ranch
flavored chip out there but not bad I
think Claudia should try these y Claudia
catch
yeah thanks Joe I've actually never had
ranch sauce or like dressing
I can already see people sort of walking
away from me the moment I start talking
to them cuz the onion the onion it's
like very potent no I'm seeing flames on
both of these I'm seeing a grill so
assumptions these are spicy enchilada
adobadas and the LA
habanas now he pretty good I know that
tastes like an enchilada
but
m t a good good they not like Takis but
they're in Takis spaces they spicy have
a a flaming hot Cheeto kind of vibe to
it Minecraft suspicious
stew limited time only thank God looks a
little gamer headset on there Shameless
Julius Pringle Shameless going after the
kids I'm surprised for something that's
clearly marketed as kids this does not
have a very strong flavor to it tastes
like a weak sour Fram onion Philly
cheese steak check out the best cheese
steak in Philadelphia Food Tours episode
starting myself and Harry
and this is that sandwich in chip form I
can't imagine one human being wanting
this avoid this oh smells terrible
there's also a french fries and ketchup
and everything bagel flavor we were not
able to get for the shoot let's
get we also have a line of scorching I
in apostrophe Pringles you can see the
steam coming out of julius's ears this
one he's crying he's crying the Buffalo
one he's not crying in the other ones
okay some look forward to start down
here with the
barbecue come on get
hot nope not scorching try the cheddar I
mean they even have the temperature
thing in the logo the thermometer going
up not only they not scorching but also
I'm not really getting any flavor I the
cheddar sour cream and onion I mean I
love sour creolin
chip they taste like sour crein chips
but I mean I'm getting a little like
lowle spice this one as you can see
Julius Pringle is crying look at this
the chip the pepper and the bottle of
hot sauce are all on
fire a little bit of heat yeah there it
is there it is okay I guess look for the
tears if you want spicy Pringles chili
and
line now instead of scorching in Italy
spicy Pringles are called Flame and you
can find them as a spicy BBQ flavor and
cheese and chili
flavor I think I'll I'll be able to have
a few without without having to go and
drink but I think it's manageable it's
like a very manageable spice let's try
the cheese and chili now this one have
two chilies on them so they're supposed
to be like the mild is ones whereas
these have
three o you're like attacked by this
cheese taste like cheese flavoring like
fake cheese taste like not nice also in
the us you can get something called the
Pringles Harvest blend four varieties to
choose from According to the ad copy a
deliciously complex tasting experience
unlike one you've ever had B ARF they're
potato chips let's embark on this taste
Journey unlike any
other The Taste difference between these
two are hardly noticeable but they
definitely look different Homestyle
Ranch also so multigrain Amazon this guy
drop kicked this to my front door this
is
ridiculous these are different than the
regular Ranch and I do like these
flavors not as strong not as insane
which I like sweet potato these next
door sweet potato and this is sea salt I
like that I like sweet
potatoes I like Maracas so okay again
the sweet potato smoky
barbecue I've definitely experienced
this before so I want to update that ad
copy the last exclusives we have is the
Lighter Side range where you can get the
lightly salted and the reduced fat
original could not get them for the time
of filming and honestly I'm glad not
interested in less salt or less fat
forget it so if I were to ran them all
let's see okay worst
Pizza didn't like the
bacon didn't like this one with the
cheese let's put the other spicy one
just because I'm I'm not so big on
spices then I'm going to put the ketchup
I'm going to put this one here and
probably the paprika is the one that I
will reach out for okay in no particular
order my favorites of the day were the
uh laus Mir habaneras very good taking
these home cheddar and sour cream always
good Scorch and series a little
disappointed except for the Buffalo my
gu crying on there so you know that uh
they're scorching and I did like the
Harvest blend ones the sweet potato ones
I sign off them here's what sucked hot
honey not hot very little honey the
Philly cheese stick thing yeah you can't
and this Minecraft suspicious stew I
don't I'm not eating anything called
suspicious that's just
weird in Italy our Pringles come in four
sizes we've got a 40 G small size you
may also be able to find a pop and go 70
G tube but we were not able to track it
down and then you can also get them in
the 175 G standard tube but if you get
the flame spicy Pringle range you only
get for the standard Tu 160 G even
though the two look exactly the same
maybe it's notes to protect you
sometimes pringers releases a three foot
tube which always breaks the internet
when it actually comes out sadly it was
not in stores right now but it looks
like it's just three tubes stacked on
top of one another so visually this is
what you will
get here in the US our Pringles come in
five sizes snack stack another little
one the grab and go the original tube
there that means that the biggest
American size is 10% larger than the
biggest Italian one we wanted to find
out how many Pringles are in a tube but
we didn't really want to count them one
by one so we're going to weigh them and
do some mats we should be getting
87.5 Pringles in each tube well the five
is maybe some like crumbles the numbers
as we've crunched here at the food Wars
math lab is 149 G total and if one chip
is 1 .9 G that equals 78.4 chips on
average per
tube in Italy the original Pringles
contain the following the original
Pringles in the US contain all of this
there aren't any major differences
except for actually coloring that we do
add to our Pringles here in Italy it's
anato uh it's made from plants and it's
totally natural I mean anato is very
dark it's like a flashy orangey Brown so
still very far from this coloring but
there is a difference with the US the
longest ingredient list for Pringles in
the US are these the scorching sour
cream and onion with 47 ingredients good
God 11 of these are main ingredients and
36 are sub ingredients now many of these
are flavoring spices and different dairy
products to create the cream flavor as
well as some colorings which you may not
have heard of before red 40 Yellow 5 and
yellow 6 there's new evidence that red
40 is triggering inflammatory bowel
disease because it is disrupting the way
the gut barrier works which is harmful
and encourages inflammation first it
scorches your tongue and then it
scorches your bow UK manufacturers were
made to remove this from their products
however it can be legally sold by EU
Imports providing it is properly labeled
may have an adverse effect on activity
and attention in children yellow number
five also called tarine is a type of
sodium salt then when eaten it becomes
sulfenic acid it is this acid that can
cause allergic reactions especially in
asthmatic people and can produce eczema
hives and also hyperactivity in children
many Nordic countries have banned its
use but is approved in the US and UK
heads up har yellow number six also
called Sunset yellow or
e110 is similar to tarine and these
colors have appeared in a bunch of
flavors these
specifically
obviously Pringles is a very well-known
brand in Italy but I think the idea of
chips as a thing for us chips are not
really a thing of their own they're like
part of a family of snacks in Italy we
tend to have chips on like a snack board
with other things other items like
olives or tiny pieces of fuka Pringles
is not the first brands that I will
reach out to it's funny cuz to me all
these seem quite a big number having to
decide between like three four five six
s seven flavor flavors and then you got
the original it's a lot we just saw the
500 different flavors they have Pringles
they're doing every flavor good for them
but as far as the classics the salt and
vinegar the barbecue the cheddar sour
cream and onion I feel like Pringles is
pretty good at uh doing most flavors but
they also had the stupid Minecraft
flavor so I don't know I don't know they
are exclusive to the Italian market but
they still do
adapted to the Italian market versus
created for the Italian market if you
wanted something very Italian you should
have put an olive oil one like you're
really missing an opportunity here just
put an olive oil flavored chip we we've
talked about some food Wars before in
America chips and snacks are all going
after each other they might be owned by
the same company and they're just like
cross-pollinating but the chip B is just
all filled with these different
iterations of the same kind of ideas so
I see tube snacks all the time I've got
actually here some of the most popular
ones we've got funes which are like
pretty much like chips you know then a
way this is a very traditional Italian
chip you also find these and these are
called crostina this is like dried bread
you know it's like a bit like crumbs you
know do you say like Crouton especially
in the south of Italy where I'm from bar
we make this all the time they're called
tarali shape is always the same but you
always get them in different flavors
actually my Grandma makes them and it's
like the best thing ever and they're
made with flour olive oil and wine so
this is like the absolute OG Italian
snack the best my grandma are better but
this is
good in the US our original regular tube
the 5.2 ounce or the 149 G is currently
$2 at Walmart in Italy our original
Pringles in the 175 G St will cost you €
30 that's about
$247 that means that in Italy we get a
23% price increase although we do get a
few more grams we want to see how much
our biggest portion of Pringles will
cost for a 48 snack stack cup variety
pack it cost
$29.78 divide that by 48 and each snack
stack cost 62 hey uh Claudia just out of
curiosity for Italian snack foods how do
Pringles compare and price compared to
other snacks that you can get in Italy
for example the tarali they actually
quite expensive and you do get only 175
gram things like these they usually sold
at bakeries for like 2 three years per
kilo so that's quite a lot of
difference in the US 100 G of original
Pringle chips contain all this that's
almost half of your recommended fat
intake for the day in Italy a 100 G
portion of original Pringles contains
the following our version actually
contains more sugar than the US one but
slightly less fat and sodum across all
Pringles flavors for calories they're
all pretty much the same now some have 1
G extra of carbs and the sodium is the
only thing that fluctuates between
flavors in Italy the flavor with the
most sodium is ketchup a 100 G serving
contains 750 mg of sodium and the us our
saltiest flavors the lasir mirus
Habaneros with
1,17 mg that's nearly half of your daily
allowance yeah British people are their
crisps
right I log in AOL to watch a Tik Tok on
my laptop this poor guy sorting them the
bet is having the worst day of his life